this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsay
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host this is your
show america it's called the ramsey show
we talk about your relationships your
jobs your mental health your career
your
oh my goodness gracious your boundaries
your crazy relatives and even your money
all of it's right here on the ramsay
show dr john deloney ramsey personality
is my co-host today dr john has a brand
new book out that is on pre-sale own
your past change your future you'll want
to pick that up and also check out his
show that is the fastest growing ramsay
network podcast right now it's called
the dr john delony show where he deals
with all kinds of mental health things
and uh some of it's uh just regular folk
uh trying to do a little better and some
of it's crazy stuff
and uh it's always entertaining i can
tell you that i love listening to it so
anyway we're here for you guys today the
phone number is triple eight eight two
five five two two five arnell is with us
to start off this hour in west palm
beach florida hey arnel what's up
hi dave hi uh dr john how are you both
better than we deserve brother what's up
uh thank you for taking my call
i wanted to get some advice on
how
we can stay motivated
we
have followed the baby steps
for a couple years now we had completed
baby step two
baby step three and
we basically fell off the bandwagon over
a period of time and now we're back in
baby step two
uh from a series of choices that we made
and
so i just wanted to you know see how we
can stay motivated um to stick with it
so that we don't end up paying off the
debt just to fall right back into it
again
[Music]
why were you getting out of debt the
first time
um
[Music]
why did it sound like a good idea to you
yeah
um mainly the
financial freedom um you know knowing
that
you know our money is for us to use for
things for the future instead of paying
for things in the past why are you
getting out of debt this time
um
sort of the same thing but um also just
kind of practically just to free up some
extra money in our monthly budget yeah
you're not gonna make it nope
not gonna make it you're gonna fall off
again
but i can help you
it's not all bad news
[Laughter]
your issue is your why
why you're doing it isn't big enough
why you're doing it right now is uh it'd
be okay
and we might be better off and
we might get us some more stuff if we
had more money yeah
instead of like i want to change my
family tree i want to look in the eyes
of my grandchildren someday and tell
them i was old man vanderbilt i was old
man rockefeller this started this dadgum
thing no one's going to take over this
branch of the family tree and take their
house ever freaking again
say the difference
your why is kind of casual
right
instead of israel
so you guys need to there has to be a
nobility to this
i want to change my family tree i want
to be outrageously generous it has to be
other centered rather than self-centered
or you won't stick with it
the people that quit drinking that are
alcoholics never do it for themselves
they always do it for someone else
or something bigger
right
same thing you guys have to come up with
a new identity
as our friend james claire said like
you've got to say
not i'm gonna i'm gonna do this anything
i am we are a family
that doesn't borrow money doesn't borrow
money and the reason we don't borrow
money is we don't like being broke and
the reason we don't like being broke is
we can't be generous and we're not and i
don't want to retire and my kids have to
take care of me because we know social
insecurity is not going to do it there
you go
i want to be able to
when gas prices go to five dollars a
gallon i want to be annoyed
not crippled i want to be i want to be
like oh man i don't want to wonder oh no
how are we going to pay our bills i want
to be able to sleep i want to be able to
breathe i don't even laugh
you got to have a much bigger
understanding of why you're doing this
yeah
and if you get a bigger why
you have a better chance of sticking it
out here's where i've seen this happen
it's mildly inconvenient you will keep
smoking oh yeah if it's just annoying or
you just stink a little bit my wife
doesn't like my breath that's not enough
she's not kissing anyway hey here's the
thing you all go out and paint a picture
of what this could look like and work
backwards yeah a big beautiful picture
in great detail high definition picture
not vague
you know pastels i'm talking where is
the house i want to see the beads of
sweat on the forehead when we're at the
beach where are the kids going to school
how much money are you giving away on a
wednesday night just to be super
generous like what
what does it look like how would it feel
to walk over and buy a single mom a car
for 2 000 and not notice
how would it feel to pay for the
adoption of a kid coming out of foster
care
so that that adoptive family could
afford to do it and that kid's life is
changing that family is changing you get
to stand back and cause that to happen
right
outrageous generosity you got to have
stuff like that in your head man because
it's
just like yeah it'd be good to have to
have payments
it just won't do it man
it's a true statement it would be good
not to have payments but you need a as
simon sinek says start with why salesmen
know that trick
like i probably shouldn't buy it they
know that trick
it's really hard to hit your head up
against no this is not who i am yeah
that's you can't sell over that ramsey's
don't borrow money
yeah ramseys are always generous yeah
it's just ramses are
you know you fill in the blank this is
who we are and you know i told my my
daughters growing up
when they were little i said ramsay
girls are smart and pretty yeah
and when they're grown women at their
rehearsal dinner their dad looks across
and i said what's a ramsay girl
and she's still smart and pretty you can
ask her today and she's on 35 years old
you can ask her what a ramsay girl is
and neither one of my ramsay girls
anymore that's right they're now crews
and whitmore's right all right so help
me with this dave let's turn the tables
help me with my parenting and mental
health so the other day
i walk out the door and i tell my
daughter who's six
good morning baby and i kissed her on
the head and she lost it
all you ever tell me is that i'm
brilliant and beautiful and strong i
can't take it anymore i don't want to
hear it anymore
and i was like i told sheila all right
mr phd you know what that is she's
wanting you to say it more i told sheila
i said i didn't have this class in grad
school i don't know what to say about
this what mean seven-year-olds
she said the other day she goes you
don't have to keep saying it dad yeah
and i said i must say it every day
i want you i want you to just be so sick
of me you're going to have to be married
to that guy
you know what 20 years what will happen
is when some 16 year old or 17 year old
little predator comes into her life
she's going to remember that she's a
precious child of god and she's special
and she's going to be looking at him
going you've got to be kidding me yes it
won't even occur to her that she's a
victim of some guy like that you've got
to be kidding me she's going to run up
against the math test and think i can't
do this she's going to go nope
i'm smart and i'm pretty i'm brilliant i
can do this somebody's gonna say you
know you have a weird face and she could
say no i'm beautiful i know i am yeah
you apparently have eye trouble
because my dad said that i was smart and
pretty and his mustache is bigger than
your gross stringy 16 year old mustache
no such thing there is no such thing as
a 15 year old mustache
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 000
about two years after that i got a
remote job that pays me and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at betheltech.net
and get 1 000 to 2500
off of your tuition again it's
betheltech
ken coleman
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at aaa
825-5225
[Music]
last week we launched the first stop on
our building wealth live tour the
response has been incredible it is
almost sold out already if you haven't
heard we're taking the building wealth
live event on the road this year doing a
couple of events this spring and four
more in the fall building wealth is a
hot topic right now everybody's got an
opinion on how to get rich quick how
crypto or single stocks or zero down
real estate or beanie babies or whatever
it is is the only way to do it we've
talked about all these topics on our
sold out event back in january the
content was
very popular so we said let's do it
again and again and again the energy in
the room was amazing our first stop on
the building wealth tour is going to be
orlando florida get ready me rachel cruz
george campbell will do the building
wealth event again dr john deloney and
ken coleman are coming with us we're all
going to be signing books dr delonie and
ken will be doing side sessions as well
uh this is may the 19th orlando it is
not yet sold out but it is approaching
it quickly if you're not in orlando stay
tuned we're going to be announcing more
cities and dates really really soon
tickets start at just 25 or you can get
a four pack for 60 which means for 60
bucks the cost of a couple of pizzas you
can bring some friends with you that's a
deal this is these tickets are
ridiculously low but we're just excited
to get back out into the marketplace
start seeing human beings in a room
together
oh so good
oh man time to do it time to get fired
up time to change things ramsay
solutions dot com slash events ramsay
solutions dot com slash events sean's in
los angeles hi sean welcome to the
ramsay show
hi dave dr john thank you so much for
taking my call sure what's up
so i have been and baby step two
aggressively paying off the only debt
that i have which is student loans for
the last three months good and um and i
have been in the just recently i was
approached by
a really good friend and a member of my
church who
um they felt impressed by the lord to
gift me a large sum of money towards
this student loan debt and it's
something i've been
praying for privately to the lord for
many many years now and the provision is
coming and so
my question is with this large sum of
money well i want to make sure that both
this person and i are both being wise
with it uh handling it
legally wisely and
if if we can avoid any potential taxes
that may come from that what is the
amount of money
the amount of money is fifteen thousand
dollars okay and evidently i'm learning
that there might be more coming okay
well he can do fifteen thousand
individual to individual in a calendar
year
without any gift tax and without any
taxes at all okay if it's more than
that
if it's more than that if he's married
his wife could give another 15 000. how
much is your student loan debt
i have about sixty thousand left okay
so you were praying and asking god to
help you pay off the student loans he
sends fifteen thousand dollars what's
the question
i just wanna make sure that we are
playing this wisely with taxes and doing
it legally because uh i want to make
sure that person is protected from any
horrendous taxes that may come from a
gift tax okay and make sure that maybe
i'm not getting taxed of the law you
have no taxes he has no taxes if it's
15. if it's more than that there is more
coming which the plan is if there's more
than that it needs to be after the after
the calendar year ends or
is he married
uh this person is single okay then uh
there's uh
he's either gonna have gift tax on it if
it's more than that or he's gonna wait
on the first of the year
um
or he can seek a tax professional's
advice there's a thing called the
unified estate tax credit if his estate
is under 20 million dollars he can give
up some of his federal exemption for
estate taxes and avoid the gift tax that
way that does require one page form to
be filed
on anything over 15 000 and he and he
permanently loses part of his
estate
deduct federal estate deduction that is
not as susceptible to federal estate tax
but if his uh net worth is under 20
million dollars then it's a non-issue
and here's another thing to think
through sean
um
this person's a grown-up making grown-up
decisions and if their grown-up decision
to give you twenty-five thousand dollars
means they gotta pay some taxes
i'm guessing if they're in a position to
write you a check for 25 grand they're
in a position to pay the tax on that
whatever so or in a position to get some
tax advice yes it's your responsibility
yeah don't don't beat yourself up take
the gift and then don't use it for
anything other than paying off your
student loans yeah because that's
exactly what you prayed for and if you
got it and then you gave something else
with it then you'd be like god's gonna
be going what yeah you know so that's
like struck by lightning kind of
[Laughter]
i think that's how that works but
probably not feels fun in my head
i'll strike you with lightning oh whoa
and you have that power do you greg is
in boston hey greg what's up
hey guys how you doing what's up man i
uh
i'll give you the dirt you tell me what
you think so i'm just trying to get a
sense of whether i should simply take
money out of the market pay off the
mortgage which is my only debt
or keep it in the market and i'll just
give you the stats and
i'll just listen from there how much do
you own your home
so i own i owe 3 30 the house is worth
550. what do you owe on what do you have
in the market
uh just just shy of 600 000 on the
market is that is that a retirement
account or just open yeah
it is in a retirement
uh um retirement and ios everything
designated for retirement savings how
old are you
58
okay
uh
no i would not i would not take it i
would not take it out of an ira or a
retirement account at 58 years old
because you're going to pay
a 10 penalty plus your tax rate on it
so about half of that about 300 000 of
that is in the retirement account the
other is liquid in the moral account oh
i misunderstood you i thought you said
it was in a return again clear my
so you have 300 000 that's not in a
retirement account and you owe 300 000
on your house
correct paid off today
interesting all right okay you want to
know why i did that
i will gladly take your time yeah okay
here's why i did that because it's the
why is important because that way you
make the same just you don't do stuff
because dave ramsey said do it you do it
because you understand why so um the uh
not because i'm scared of biden or all
the other crap in the stock market's
going crazy and the inflation and
all this stuff it's not that at all i
would have given you the exact same
advice five years ago 10 years ago 15
years ago because we know from data that
we have collected on millionaires that
the shortest distance between where you
are right now and a multi-million dollar
net worth is to become 100 debt free
because it lowers risk and increases
cash flow
so
many millions we studied 10 we studied
10 000 millionaires and the vast
majority of them that got their first 1
to 5 million of net worth which you
don't quite yet have but you're well on
your way you've done a really good job
had a paid off home
and a beefy 401k
and a roth ira in good growth stock
mutual funds so a lot of them had like a
million and a half dollar net worth a
paid off six hundred thousand dollar
home and seven eight hundred thousand
bucks in
their 401k and it took them you know 15
years or so to get those two goals
accomplished and that's the the
standard template model of a millionaire
that we have studied and found to be
true
and so given that we know that if you
don't have a house mortgage you make
different decisions in your career you
have a tendency to make more money if
you don't have a house mortgage you have
more money because you don't have house
payment to put into and fund your
investments and your investments grow
faster and faster and faster and faster
and faster so the whole thing the
lowered risk and the increased cash flow
causes the wealth to blow up and that's
why i said to do that and it's why i
didn't even hesitate and again it has
absolutely nothing to do with the
current condition of the stock market
the geopolitical climate the crazy butt
inflation uh i just filled up my truck
and a
holy hundred dollars i mean it's just
unbelievable i get it i understand a lot
of you are afraid you're freaking out
don't make financial decisions based on
freak out make financial decisions based
on principles that work in good times
and in bad times this is the ramsey shop
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage naaman
and gabrielle are with us hey guys how
are you you're doing well dave great how
are you doing better than we deserve
brother welcome so good to have you so
how much debt did you two pay off we
paid off seventy five thousand three
hundred and fifty eight dollars i love
it how long did this take you ten months
and eighteen days oh
there we go
and your range of income during that
time um back then we were making about
fifty eight thousand to then 90 000.
that's a nice jump in the year way to go
so where do y'all live
venice florida oh yeah cool what do you
do for a living i'm a machinist i'm a
cnc machinist and i'm a nurse all right
so what why'd this income double what'd
you do she graduated yeah
she got a job i like it where'd it go
it's about time gabriel
that's fantastic that's so cool good for
y'all how long you been married
um just over one year yeah cool how old
are you 21 22. and so what kind of debt
was this 75 000 all student loans yep
got rid of sally may yeah okay so i i i
have to know how in the world is
somebody 21 years old 22 years old this
brilliant that you decide the first
order of business as
newlyweds is to get really sally may
cause we really don't want a roommate
since we just got married
we wanted to set up our future for you
know our future family and changing our
changing our family tree
yeah but when i was 21 my future was
about look how big this truck is
how did you guys definitely that's one
of tesla yeah that's fair he wants one
but he didn't get one he got out of
sallie mae exactly
yeah
what got you in this what in the world
how did you know to do this how did you
get connected to us
so i kind of just found you guys on
youtube um
um it was probably about a year and a
half two years into our relationship and
you know i was getting ready i graduated
high school and i knew that this was
going to be serious and i was wanting to
spend the rest of my life with her and
um
you know i wanted to um
be able to support our family and
be able to be the better leader of our
household you know and so i wanted to
learn about finances and so i went onto
youtube and i found your found your
videos and i just got into it and just
watched non-stop videos and then she was
hearing me talk about it saying i'm
listening to some crazy guy
was he driving you crazy a little bit
but i thought he was obsessed and then i
started listening to and um i just
agreed with everything so
we started listening together and just
jumped right on board he
started saving
when you started working as soon as you
graduated you know i've always been a
saver and so i was able to thankfully
thank the lord i was able to save so
much and you know cash flow our wedding
and um you know and then have some
savings to pile in to when we get
married we both had savings we could
throw at it and
um yeah
why to go you guys you're amazing you
are an amazing power couple at 21 22
years old very well done
so uh
i'm curious naaman uh
i actually just did a pod recorded a
podcast yesterday with my buddy mike
rowe who does dirty jobs and he's a big
proponent as i am of the of people
considering
going into a trade so we've got a a
a nurse
with a ton of education and we've got
you coming out of high school and you go
straight into a trade you're making bank
in the trade you're doing very very well
what made you decide to go that route so
i had a neighbor down the street that i
was doing yard work for on on summers
you know and
and i told him i wanted to go and get my
mechanical engineering degree and he
said you know you should probably go and
learn how things are made and you know
learn how to make things with your hands
and you know know the engineering behind
how things are made and so i looked into
it and it was just a year-long course at
a technical college and
right when i graduated i was placed into
a job and
you know i was blessed yeah so is your
future goal to ultimately go back and
get a mechanical engineering degree yes
yes i would like to do that you will be
the best yeah mechanical engineer
because you actually know how crap works
it's not theory yeah wow your neighbor's
a genius that's a wise neighbor yeah
very wow
who were your biggest cheerleaders as
you guys were doing this
uh i'd say each other and um
at work uh i worked as a cna before
while i was doing school and uh i
when i started as a nurse i took all the
overtime that i could
and uh people were asking why are you
working so much what are you doing what
are you saving up for and um i told them
you know we're saving up to pay off all
our debt and uh people are asking how
we were doing it and um did they just
saw that we were different and i sus
people would start coming up to me and
being like oh i paid off my car or i'm
signing up for six shifts this week and
it was just really motivating to hear
and people started listening to or some
of the girls at work started listening
to the show at work
and all for their own reasons but um it
was just really motivating to hear like
oh i did this or
uh they're just seeing that we're
different and uh and we listen to your
guys's show you know every day and so we
had motivation from other people doing
their jeffery screams yeah and
that was really what you know kept us
going
but a 21 year old and a 22 year old
y'all are the youngest people in your
work area by a decade
y'all were a little bitty light that
blew everybody out of darkness people
could suddenly see a whole new path yeah
like y'all are changing a bunch of
family trees yeah that's fantastic
you're reminding me all cause you
stumble onto youtube man who would have
thunk it yeah that's amazing yeah i love
it you guys are something i always tell
people don't don't follow what you hear
on youtube i'm wrong let it go
way to go man
with the exception of the ramsey
this is actually information you can
count on yeah good very good so uh what
do you tell people the key to getting
out of debt is you did it you're actual
professionals
um i say
just dreaming together we had a vision
and we knew what we wanted to work
towards and that we wanted to start
having kids sooner rather than later and
um get a house so we
made a clear path and um we just like we
were newly married so it was hard so
sacrifice sacrificing time we wanted to
spend all the time we could together um
so we just had to be intentional about
just um when we did have days off just
you know sitting down talking to each
other and still
making sure we had the same vision and
i was learning that you know it was all
about
you know the more you can sacrifice in
the short term it compounds and it's
just beneficial in the long term
you know um when i was when we were
doing our debt free journey
i was constantly listening to total
money makeover while i was working the
audiobook and three or four times
it's probably seven or eight times but
oh yeah that was just better than i did
and you know and some reason i wasn't
understanding the point of getting rid
of all non-retirement you know and i had
i had my beloved tesla stock that i had
purchased and it grew and i really loved
that and it came down close to the end
and i'm like i want to get out of this
dead you know i want to i want to move
up move up the bar you know we thought
we were going to get done in january
then we said december then we said
november you know and so i sold out all
that because i know that it's more
beneficial for our future yeah when he
told me that i was like i had to clean
up my ears i was like did you really
what he did so how much beloved tesla
stock did you have how many dollars
worth it was five thousand all right
look at you
that was a big that that's a big jump
and he wants a tesla too so he's totally
brought in you know
he's a big elon musk i'm just saying way
to go guys
very fun
very fun well we're incredibly proud of
you you are an impressive impressive
young couple you give old geezers like
me hope that there's future with people
like you guys running around so well
done we got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you that's the next
chapter in your story for sure you'll be
there before you know it and that
tesla's on the way you're gonna get you
one if that's what you want anyway
and uh also a copy of total money
makeover uh make sure you get one we get
that and maybe one of your buddies who's
just getting started on this stuff you
can give it away to them so good stuff
good stuff you guys are amazing very
very impressive congratulations neyman
and gabrielle are gay is it gabrielle
gabriel gabrielle good in sarasota
florida 75 000 paid off in 10 months
making 58 to 90 21 and 22 years old shut
up count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream three three two one we're
debt-free
[Applause]
[Music]
so if you're listening or watching today
and you have 80 000 in student loan debt
that was for you
that says
that this can be done one year and you
should do it 10 months baby
game on but you sell the beloved
dot dot dot fill in the blank this is
the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five
two two five robertson chicago hi robert
welcome to the ramsey show
hey
happy fun patrick's day how are you
today
better than i deserve sir what's up in
your world
good uh so the basis of my question uh
relates to the funds that should be in a
custodial account for my son
i know for your i know you mentioned uh
you know past videos i've seen where
when you purchase your real estate you
paid in cash but you have like a s p 500
fund that you just stock away money and
then when you're ready to purchase
something you just take your money out
and
pay cash for it so currently um and my
son's one year old one years old by the
way
but right now i just have a single s p
500 fund
so any money that comes in you know from
gifts
and things like that i just put it
towards that fund
so i'm not sure if that fund's fine for
him or if i should you know break it
down to four separate funds like you
recommend for you know retirement
accounts
oh that's fine i'll just leave it in
that i mean if it gets to be 500 000 or
something you may want to move it around
but i don't think it will
i mean you're probably if you if it ends
up being 100 grand it'll be a great day
right
right yeah because uh it's going to be
there for him until he turns 21 then
it's you know his money but you know
just to make sure you know i just wasn't
too sure when i was
buying the same fund yesterday and
you know putting a good amount of money
towards it so that's why i was curious
yeah i wouldn't worry about it if it
gets to where it's large enough that you
start to feel uncomfortable
diversification is safety and the only
reason to move it into to diversify the
funds is to make it a little safer a
little calmer but an s p is pretty
stinking calm it's going to follow the
market
be as wild as the market's going to be
um so you know but that overall over a
long period over a 20-year period of
time that's a fairly close
it's not a high risk investment i mean
you're not buying gold you're not buying
oil futures you're not buying bitcoin
you're not buying lotto tickets you know
you're this is a conservative investment
in in the realm of investing so i think
you're just fine there i also would make
sure though that your funding is 529 for
his education as well
um that that is more important or at
least equally important
as this and so i we always talk about
the the fact that 529 grows tax-free
so it doesn't matter what funds you've
got in it you could put it in four you
could put in one you can put it in
whatever um but yeah the the
the you know uh uh
uniform utm account a uniform transfer
to miners account is what you've got
which anytime you open an account for a
child that's under 21 years old it's it
is in your name it's in the kid's name
and you're the custodian
and that's a utma uniform transfer to
minors act so any of your parents if
you've opened your kid a checking
account or a
savings account at the bank or anything
like that that's what it all falls under
is that that piece of the law
uh and it will be taxed at the kids rate
if the kid has any taxes
and they usually don't because there's
usually not enough money in there that
it makes enough money to to activate
taxation and thank you for being a dad
robert who
is thinking about their kid
yeah most parents get the 20 in the mail
and they just stick it in their wallet
or in their purse and you're thinking
way down the road good for you man yeah
that's good
really good stuff really really
excellent all right tonya is with us
tonya is in new york city hi tanya how
are you
hi dave hi john
been listening to you guys since may
2020 thank the pandemic
um i'm currently yes
i'm currently on baby step two
um with a student loan
six thousand dollars and car carly's i
know don't hate me save uh six thousand
dollars i bring home 6500 a month
my car leaves in february 2023.
um i have a baby step three questions
what do i do first do i save for the
three to six emergency fund or save for
my next car
three to six emergency fund
okay
okay the car the car upgrades and
couches and home purchases and vacations
and all those things are fine after you
have an emergency fund in place but if
you do those things without an emergency
fund in place you are inviting an
emergency 100 yeah sure you'll have it
yeah you're just kind of like looking at
the rain clouds going rain on me
taking all of your precious things in
the yard and saying you won't rain on me
do it do it yeah just make sure you
finish the you know and so we stay
gazelle intense until we get through
baby step three thousand dollars in the
bank is one be debt free but the house
is baby step two emergency fund of three
to six months of expenses that's the
foundation that you build your life on
financially and so you stay very intense
very focused don't buy anything until
you get those three things done when
you've got those things done then you
save up and you get a better couch you
get a better car you get a better house
you get a better whatever it is um and
you're paying cash for the move up and
all of that of course so we don't go
back into debt
but that's exactly how that you move
from intensity to intentionality at that
point i love that and
dave just as you said that i think
there's got to be people in other parts
of the world
as people are taking notes like what now
what now okay pay everything off and
then have some savings okay got it
that we think wow
we are we are building rockets in here
we are building rockets
oh josie is with us in
in cincinnati hi josie what's up
hi dave hi john um it's great to talk to
you guys i've been listening for a long
time
um so
yeah john this question might be more
directed towards you
um so me and my husband have um just
recently in the last year gotten out of
debt
um and i guess
the thing i'm struggling with is
how do i talk to my parents about doing
the same thing um
i have talked to them about it
previously
my i come from a big family and so my
parents have always worked really hard
to provide for our family
and to
keep food on the table keep the lights
on um but i think that's about all
they've been able to do
um
and now that i'm older and i see what
this feels like this freedom and
like i want this for them um
you're newly sober
and you want everybody to stop having a
glass of wine because it feels so great
right
and or you just discovered the keto diet
now you want everyone or you just went
fully vegan like you are debt free and
you are sleeping like you haven't slept
your marriage is good
um
sex and money
are two conversations you can't have
with your parents
about their sex and their money
and so what i did one year for my family
years ago is i this is back in the olden
days i printed out a binder with a
year's worth of budget
outlines that i i got off dave's
original website years ago i bought
everybody in my family total money
makeover
and that was it
that was my gift for christmas and they
loved it it was good we had
conversations and but
when my mom invites me into that
conversation she'll
ask an occasional question my dad went
and moved some retirement stuff after
his parents passed away recently asked
me some questions about it
but i wait for them to invite me in
i'm not going to be able to go tell my
parents that i and i know how hard that
is because you are feeling it for the
first time and everything is through
that lens right now
the thing they're not gonna hear it
there's two other things you can add to
that equation
um
you can never bring their finances up to
them but you can talk about your story
and how good it feels
and never even say a word about theirs
just tell them your story and how great
you feel
and um
you know i uh you know i just feel so
much better i just you know i mean we
don't fight about money we've got
control the future's bright huh
wow it's just one of the best things
i've ever discovered and you just keep
talking about your story and how you did
how you did it and what you did
and nobody can really argue with you
about your story um and eventually they
might say
well i could never do that
well you and you could say well you
might if you ever want me to help you i
would there you go or something like
that
that's a long way from you shaking your
finger at them going you people need to
straighten up
because they're not going to
that way the second thing you can do is
sometimes you can talk to someone that
has influence in their life
that talks to them about this subject
and they might listen to that person
a pastor an older brother your uncle in
other words that kind of thing
but that seldom works either honestly
but the other one will work tell them
your story
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's john deloni co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career
you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host dr john
deloney ramsey personality is my co-host
today open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
we're here to talk about your
relationships your boundaries your
mental health your job your career your
money all of it right here every day
on the ramsay show tyler is in
pennsylvania starting this hour hey
tyler what's up
hey guys how are we doing today better
than i deserve what's up
all right so i'm looking to get some
advice um i'm currently making around 40
000 a year um
and
i don't know what my next move should be
um i pay around 900 for rent um and i
have one kid now and another kid coming
in around this week we're due on the
25th congratulations
thank you thank you my wife is um a
stay-at-home mom
and so you know we're kind of just
working with my income right now um i
have around 5000 in savings i have my
401k i have stock you know i'm trying to
see what i can do and you know i just
need some guidance in what my next step
should be in housing
you're doing very well congratulations
how old are you thank you
19. oh thanks wow
what do you do for a living
so i work i do like sales and food
service it's kind of both um it's kind
of like a convenience store but it's um
a better growth convenience store if
that makes sense you're having baby
number two at 19.
yes yes dude my mom gave me a talking to
at 19 before i got a dog she's like i
don't think you're ready for this
you are in it brother so how old were
you when you had the first one
i was 17. wow you're just getting after
it huh so your hands are full okay so um
what is your
35 year old you gonna be doing for a
career
oh man i i have dreams of kind of being
retired and uh you know i look to you
dave as you know a huge mentor as i'm a
new listener i don't want you to be
retired at 35. i want you to be making
two million a year what is it you're
going to be doing
um
i don't i don't really know yet um you
know i'm working for a good company i
get you know and there's an esop program
i get a good 401k
um
i'm looking to
get into real estate at some point i'm
also really interested into stocks
you know i have a lot of options due to
me being young but you know i don't
really have a
set journey yet
okay well yeah you you've um
you know in one sense you're 19 and you
shouldn't have all this figured out in
another sense you're making 40 000 and
have two kids so you gotta start
figuring it out
you know because here's the thing you uh
you're going to hit what you aim at
and if you aim at nothing
you will hit it every time
and the chances of you opening your eyes
at 27 making 40 000 for the same company
are strong to quite strong if you're not
headed somewhere yeah exactly
and so the way we solve your rent
problem
is
in the short term you have to be very
careful and manage and and pick out a
good property and just kind of deal with
life with two kids and super young
marriage and all that and um you'll
laugh about these days later on and go
back in our 23 we were starving to death
but um you know but the but for right
now it's just a pain in the butt
and uh but but the the way you overcome
this is you are aiming at something
further down the road and that will have
so let's just pretend let's pretend that
over the next few months or even years
you decide you want to be doing
something and you just give it a name
whatever the thing is and you're going
to be you know doing real estate and i'm
going to be making 100 000 a year when
i'm 30 years old okay once you start
saying that a lot
and start to believe it and start to
study how what you have to do to make
that come true uh you know what must be
true that is not true today for me to be
there then immediately you start moving
off of the 40 and start moving up
which starts to solve some of the
immediate problems as well
and so that's why i'm asking you all of
that instead of answering your 900 rent
question because
truthfully it's not going to be easy
to rent a property and feed two kids on
forty thousand dollars
you can do it
but you don't wanna do that for a decade
doing it for 10 months while we're
heading to something else and i'm not
teaching you to be dissatisfied with
your job i'm just saying even if it's
inside this company when you start
talking about the super talk of the
supervisors and the managers what about
what do i have to what value can i add
to this organization so that i can move
up because i got two little babies i
gotta feed and i'm trying to be
ambitious and uh wise beyond my ears and
show me how to do that and you'll be
when you start talking that and thinking
that and being that and identifying that
that's who you are that's when the
income's going to start to change that's
why you hear people calling this show
tyler that almost every single debt-free
scream during the
time they were getting out of debt
increased their income
now some of them just did it they took
an extra job pay off debt but some of
them walked into the boss's office and
said what can i do to add value
and the boss goes well you know what i
haven't given you a raise in a while
here's another 20 grand and ding ding
you know it's just stuff like that
happens all the time but it's because
you're paying attention to it
and there's something magical about
sitting down with a supervisor or maybe
not even your supervisor but somebody
one step ahead of you and say hey can i
buy you some cup of coffee like walk me
through your arc here when'd you start
here how did you get to this role people
love to tell their story and you're
going to pick up a lot of wisdom along
the way about how your group operates
how the groups around you operate hang
on the line here and jenna will get your
information we'll send you a copy of
ken's book from paycheck to purpose that
just walks you through that process but
start thinking and dreaming big in the
meantime
keep your rent low yeah in the meantime
find it out manage your budget
and uh live like no one else so that
later you can live and give like no one
else in the meantime
you're gonna live in a place that you
don't want to live in for very long
but you'll live there for a little while
i did when i was your age i did too and
and it's not to say that it's mandatory
to do that but it's just to say that
there's no shame in that
i'm okay if you could live in a really
wonderful place because you were making
200 000 a year that wouldn't make me mad
at all either i'm not it doesn't it's
not required that you have hard times
but you are square in the middle of some
so you might as well get the getting
might as well get what's there to get
good for you man you're just a stud man
unbelievable gosh
i'm
i'm not sure i could have dialed the
number to call this show no when i was
19 the number of 19 year olds i've
worked at that can't figure out where
the intramural office is good grief
trying to check out some ping pong
paddles and i can't find the like oh my
gosh
and this guy's
having a second kid it's amazing
well it'll grow you up i can tell you
that and obviously is he's wise beyond
his you're a good young man you call us
anytime we can help hold on proud of you
general pick up and give you a copy of
coleman's book and we'll move you along
to the next next fantastic really cool
wow
wow
this is the day that i feel old the 19
year old this is the day
well shut up i just caught up just today
suddenly i mean the 21 year olds and the
19 year olds and it's like oh my
goodness america dave needs a mirror
well i've got you john
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
thanks for joining us america this is
the ramsey show we're so glad you're
with us dr john dolone ramsey
personality is my co-host
and uh dr john baloney came to our
product team and they came up with this
very wild idea conversation cards
uh for adults a conversation cards for
families and we've got them for several
categories right how many categories um
yeah there's ones for
people who have been married for a while
that help you get a little bit deeper in
your relationship and then for
families grandparents and kids and
everybody in between and then there's
ones for just friends hanging out okay
and just the conversation starters
that's right and i probably promptly
laughed and i went we've reached the
point in america that we actually need a
deck of cards to have a conversation
this is absolutely freaking ridiculous
these things will never never sale and
they have sold thousands tens of
thousands they're going to pay my house
off i'm telling you i've never seen a
product like this i love it when i'm
wrong like this i do too
so
they have challenged me to get involved
especially since i was so negative
uh with the conversation cards so you've
got some of them
so this is how this works this is how
this works i'm just pulling up so
imagine me and you are getting chips in
queso or just having a conversation from
a couple of 10 million people
what's one word or phrase that's way
overused
literally literally oh literally he's
the worst literally
rachel cruz literally everything
literally the word i can't stand is the
word awesome
and i say it
it sounds like an old like sad my past
teacher our pastor friend has a fit
about that because he says that word
should be reserved for god it's okay and
i say it all the time too like i'm some
kind of surfer boy or something well it
sounds like an old youth minister in
shorts like you're awesome yeah and
we're like we shouldn't be saying this
but yeah it's yeah it's a great word but
it is yeah overused all right what
physical activity well dave's out on
that one what's physical activity or i'm
just being ugly today
physical activity or
whooping on john this is
anyone at say it again what physical
activity or sport could you defeat
pretty much anyone at
none
um
but i am uh in the top one percent on a
water ski or barefooting you are
incredible at that so um and i'm 61
years old that's still barefoot so
that's you know that that does put you
up there i saw you get off the back of
the boat
i couldn't believe if i hadn't been
there i would have thought they were
exaggerating when you were on the back
of the boat
and then you took the key the
rope and threw it into the back of the
boat and you had
we were surfing that surf everybody surf
so we're just surfing i've never seen
that well it's really impressive when
you've never seen it but it's not that
hard so i just saw you on some sort of
device behind the boat nothing was
pulling you and you were still following
the boat that's that's surfing yeah
that's bad lots of people do that that a
lot of people are gonna be going john
that's not that impressive but
um yeah we've been doing it since nobody
was doing it that's for sure we started
doing it we had to get our own little
board and figure it out and then it
suddenly became a thing now they build
boats just to do that
what's a movie or tv show that you're
ashamed to admit you watched downton
abbey
[Laughter]
lost my man card on that one you like
every episode
yeah lost my man card on that one for
sure oh man without hesitation boom just
like that you liked it oh i loved it
yeah completely lost my man carter
the music just ding ding ding ding down
the whole thing
[Music]
if you can't see if you're listening on
podcast dave is actually hugging himself
right now
when he just said that no his arms are
crossed in a bad body language position
he is not he's hugging himself all right
what's the strangest thing you know
about your family history
uh
you can repeat on the air yeah really um
well on the one side i had a group that
had my two great grandfathers were both
preachers one of them was a circuit
riding preacher
and on the back of a mule went around
all throughout the south and i've got
his bible from the 1800s that he carried
in the saddlebags wow that's on the one
side on the other side
someone murdered one of the ramses
and uh the the widow was pregnant
and when the baby was born 18 years
later she handed him
her his dad's gun and said the guys in
montana go kill him and he did
so so you come back creatures on one
side and we got this other thing on the
other side so i don't know yeah it's
it's wild
so america if you don't think genetics
are a place years later
hillbilly will send you your the son
of your father to that you kill to come
kill you i mean this is that's that's
hillbilly stuff right there man wow
that's fantastic dave
i think like i'm not usually speechless
that's incredible and i'm looking at the
manifestation of that right now
and you've been making fun of me just
keep this in mind i'm quiet now yeah
just want to tell you that you're
looking great
looking kind of young you're looking
younger than i've ever seen you yeah you
look fast too like you could just run
fast
that's incredible
questions for humans everybody man you
get a group of people around the table
and that is fun i have to admit oh yeah
it's pretty cool you dig up something
and get to talking about something other
than just stupid stuff tell your friends
that you can not talk about covet and
not talk about whatever it is not a
coveted question or a politics question
in this thank you jesus not in this debt
no vaccine questions no thank you jesus
we did think about coming up with
another deck on ending friendships and
it's just going to be all
stuff
when you answer this question
trump is the greatest ever true or false
go
[Laughter]
people who don't get vaccines are evil
go like we're just gonna we're gonna
clear your friend deck for you
we're gonna sell that deck at a hundred
dollars a piece you're gonna separate
the sheep and the goats right here y'all
can just move over so here's the fun
thing we're going to give you
when you buy two copies of john's new
book own your past change your future
one for you and one for a friend if you
use the promo code friends
when you check out you'll get the
friends edition of questions for humans
for free we will throw in this highly
expensive deck of conversation cards as
a bonus this is dave revenge for me
giving away tmmo every episode you're
now giving away the questions for humans
carl and and
another book yeah so there you go with
john's book and the questions for human
cards you will laugh for sure you'll
probably cry you may get mad you'll
definitely learn something and you'll
start connecting at a meaningful level
ramsey solutions.com get two copies of
john's new book one for you one for
someone else own your past change your
future there's all kinds of add-ons when
you buy that and put the promo code
friends in and we will also now in
addition to the other stuff throw in
the uh friends edition of the
conversation start very cool free and
that's a big bonus because these things
are selling we really don't have to give
them away no yeah we're not really going
to be stuck with them or anything
they're going to sell goodness gracious
and then you can call my show to find
out what happens when you find out that
your boss has a murderer in the family
wow hey
far enough back that you know that
doesn't affect me it is not far enough
back doesn't affect me why do you just
keep that in mind that i'm just scooting
over right now gabriel
gabrielle is with us in atlanta hi
gabrielle how are you
hi i'm i'm nervous but excited how are
you dave better than i deserve john's in
rare form you should be nervous what's
up
um so i am a elementary teacher i have
been that for nine years now i make um
close to 60k
i have over a little bit over a hundred
and ten thousand dollars in student
loans
and
i'm a single parent
um when i'm i'm currently a part of the
loan forgiveness program uh four years
in um by being a part of that program
they base how much i have to pay off of
my debt to income ratio and the fact
that i have a daughter that i support
um by the end of the program after 10
years i would only pay a little bit over
31 000.
um i've been reading your book love it
um i completed it a year ago and i
started to listen to the podcast about a
month ago the money makeover book um so
i'm on baby step number two i've knocked
out credit card debts and trust personal
loans and now i'm sitting with the
student loans and i'm wondering
do i just hang on for the ride for the
loan forgiveness program because it's
going to mean i pay back less
or do i now try to figure out some way
of continuing as a teacher and being a
single mom and figuring out how to get
good zeal about paying this debt off
when i do the math there are questions
there's three times the student loans
are forgiven disability death and the
private student loan forgiveness program
726 811 people had applied for the
program that you're on
seven hundred and fifty thousand people
applied for it as of the end of the year
so far eight thousand have gotten it one
percent are getting it it's a lie
you need to pay off your student loans
do not sit and wait on that it's not
going to happen the government lied to
you they are not doing it the actual
numbers are in 1.6 so far have actually
gotten their forgiveness the rest did
not it's a lie i'm sorry
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchhillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
america open phones at triple h
825-5225 brandon is with us in denver
hey brandon how are you
i'm good dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
okay so
this has happened before with my sister
this is basically what it's about
so my sister i'm 27 years old
and my sister is 46 she'll be 47 in
april
and she always seems to have trouble
financially
and recently
she asked me for a hundred dollars
and i'm not sure if she's aware that i
know that she owes my mom 800.
and
i kind of wanted to like offer her
advice and help her out
but i in my mind i feel like she's going
to live okay what is this 27 year old
punk trying to school me on anything
he's the one with a hundred dollars you
don't have that's who he is yeah i know
i yeah no i can
i get it and it's a little frustrating
because i feel like if it was
i feel like if anyone's asking for money
it should be it should be the other way
around
but you know it's like i don't know
exactly how to bring it up to her
because i don't want to i feel like my
mom and dad always end up
giving her money and i've always told
them like you know this isn't really
helping her it's more so perpetuating
her mismanagement of money
and
i guess i just don't know how to go
about it without causing a whiff between
us
so i want you to re re-approach the
situation you did not cause the rift the
rift was thrown at you
all you are doing now is responding to
the rift okay
and as simple as
uh um
no i i'm not gonna loan you a hundred
dollars thank you though
anything after that is you trying to
smooth over your boundary and that's not
your responsibility
so there's a simple peaceful answer i'm
not going to judge the fact that you owe
mom i'm not going to explain stuff to
you unless you invite me into that
conversation i'm just going to tell you
no um i'm not going to not going to loan
you 100 bucks all right john that's not
how this ends though no then it's like
why not exactly you're not just gonna
you know what does he say when she says
well why not
because that's exactly what she's gonna
say yeah why not entitled brat oh you
mean you can't even
yeah i'm just gonna choose not to and if
you wanna go down the road of well well
then what
because this is going to cause a rift
between you and me and our relationship
but i'm not going to do that
and this is you drawing a boundary that
no one's ever drawn from her you know
what that's going to feel like to her
abuse
oh my goodness hatred
you here's the thing you can't control
her response to your boundary
you can't yeah i guess the thing is is
like i do feel kind of bad this was
about a week ago she asked me and i
didn't even respond to her because i'm
just like i had nothing froze i'm just
like
in my mind i'm thinking are you serious
right now
yeah
good hey and good for you for not
lashing out for taking a break okay
that's that's wisdom
yeah no you're you're smart
because putting the snark on it that you
that we all want to tell her it's not
gonna be helpful me included it's not
it's not helpful okay that it does not
help her so the goal here is to help her
yeah
okay
and so john let me ask you is there a
way that you can couch this i get that
the boundary is simple
um no
i i'm not able to do that at this time
well i'm choosing not to do that
whatever i'm not i'm not willing to do
that at this time
okay well why not yeah
um is it okay to then is is it
productive then to say you know what i
would choose to do
is if you will go through this class
financial peace university that costs
100 i'll pay for it for you yeah
so so that you can learn how to handle
money so you never ask anybody for money
again because i've watched you struggle
and it breaks my heart
yes and well the thing is is i know that
she um
her and her husband because she does
door dash on the side and her husband's
a breadwinner but he makes really good
money
and um
i know they i think hired a financial
advisor like months ago but apparently
obviously didn't really do anything
or the financial advisor is an idiot
more than two yeah and or that financial
advisor has that cash flow right has to
do with other things here's the thing
when she when she has to redo it finds
herself in a situation where she has to
go to her brother her 20 year younger
brother and ask for money
she's already in a in if not already she
is in dangerously close to the
fight-or-flight place anyway she's
something has come up that has pushed
her to this area and then you say no and
every alarm she's got is going to start
ringing and so
while what dave said is when you if you
sit down have a cup of coffee with her
and say can we talk in person yes i care
about you a lot this has come up a lot i
know you've you've been with mom and dad
i want to see this i want to help
100 is not going to help it might bail
you out of a thing you think you have
but in that moment usually people can't
hear me that's why i always i always
recommend wait to be invited in
if you want my money here's what it's
going to come with you're going to sit
down you have to have a cup of coffee
with me so maybe that's the angle i'll
give you 100 bucks but you have to meet
me in person and you have to listen to
what i have to say
and that may be where you have a little
bit um
that's kind of the i mean i'm visiting
back because i'm originally from
maryland i'm not from colorado yep so
i'm visiting home soon
and that's kind of something i'm a
little nervous about visiting because i
don't know if this her but i think it's
also kind of a good opportunity as
you're saying to kind of sit down with
her and talk to her because
i just it's been going on
i think ever since she got married for
like 18 years that's been going on
because apparently she used to have a
better credit score than my dad
so and now her credit score is like
really not good yeah she's got bigger
things going on and maybe that's the
angle as you sit down with her and say i
want to take you to breakfast or take
you to lunch and then say you're really
worried about your life you asking your
little brother for what's going on are
you okay and when she says what do you
mean i'm fine i'm fine you say you just
asked your little brother for a hundred
dollars you're not okay
and that becomes an angle that is going
to give you permission into speaking to
her and what's going on in her soul
right
but the end of the deal the end of the
story is regardless of her reaction or
her choice
to respond in any of these conversations
under no circumstances do you give her a
hundred dollars
except
in the event that she is going to plug
into things that cause her
to start winning with money so that she
never has to ask for it again
yeah that's kind of my angle that's been
my angle for a while because i even get
upset with my parents because she's
asking for money before
and i only gave her money one time she's
probably asking for money like five
times um and i said no all the other
four times uh the very first time i said
yes all the other times i said no she
even asked me if i could co-sign for her
daughter for a car and i said absolutely
not
good for you know all about that so this
is this is long term it's been going on
for a while so i think this fifth time
she's asked you and it's a small and you
know i think the other thing you do do a
john deloney and say this by the way is
the last time we're going to have this
discussion right is it
because the next time you call me for
money i'm just going to tell you no and
you're going to know what i meant when i
said no yeah because i don't need to
cover this
yeah well she knew because even because
she texted me she didn't really even
call me which sounds weird but she
texted me and she was like i know you
don't like giving me money it's like
well yeah you know i don't it's not even
like but it's not you though it's like i
just don't like giving people money
like money that i've worked for i mean
if i i'm all about giving people gifts
and maybe like charity and volunteering
and stuff like that but
it's like repetitive and my parents i
get kind of like i don't i know i can't
do much about them but when they keep
giving her money i always tell them like
please don't do that because it's like
it's like you're they're digging a hole
well you're giving a drunk a drink
they're taking the half themselves to
give to put somebody out of one and it's
just like but here's the deal you said
it and i want to reiterate it you can't
do anything about what they're doing
and so you you spoke in your piece to
your your parents
i would get out of their head i'd get
out of their decision-making process and
don't don't let them have don't let this
issue have any more real estate in your
brain it's a real simple thing i'm
willing to help my sister when i in a
way that i am really helping her
not in a way that i am giving a drunk a
drink it's very simple and if she does
not want to participate in that then i'm
unwilling to have any more conversations
even about this until she is okay and i
know i'm your little brother i know this
is weird this is where we are yeah i
mean i know it feels weird because
you're old enough to be my mother you
know i mean she's 20 years his senior
and so uh that is very weird it's not a
classic sibling relationship
um and so
yeah you just say you know i i here
here's the here's my terms
and they're all for your good
i don't need the hundred dollars i could
give you a thousand dollars
but none of this is going to help you uh
but i want to really help you and
something's clearly not okay yeah she's
got bigger problems than a hundred
dollars heartbroken a lot bigger
problems and because they're chronic
they're ongoing yeah
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you for joining us america
this is the ramsay show dr john deloney
ramsey personality is my co-host today
best-selling author and host of the book
of the podcast the dr john daloni show
be sure and join it it's right here on
ramsey networks uh paul is with us in
sacramento hey paul how are you
i'm walking on to the break of dawn hey
yo what's up paul i stole that from you
i like you oh my a dr john fan okay
what's up all right all right so
i'm gonna give you my whole life and
financial picture i'm 19 years old
i'm planning on getting married in the
next two years and then i want to rent
for two years after that
so i'm looking to buy a house in
probably four to five years from now
i have forty thousand dollars in cash
right now
and i'm thinking of putting that in an s
p 500
until i'm ready to buy a house and just
keep adding to that
but my mom says that
i should probably that i should hold
that as cash
in case a good deal comes up or
something like that just
to have that cash ready on me on hand
because i'm going to be going through a
lot of changes
so you can get it out of an s p 500 in
20 minutes
yeah it's as liquid as your savings
account is as far as getting a hold of
it the downside is the stock market
might be down that day
or that week or that month
and so i mean if 40 thousand dollars if
it had a 10 drop in the stock market
that would be an unusually bad year
statistically unusually bad year
and that would have cost you 4 000
if the stock market is up 10 15 you're
gonna make four five six thousand
dollars per year doing this so if you
can handle emotionally the swing of you
may make
four or five or six and you might lose
four that's probably your over and under
on the thing then the s p 500 is okay if
you can handle all of that
right the chances of it of your 40
turning into 20 is
very very very low
it's only happened a couple of times in
history
the chances of your 40 turning into 80
in one year
never happened
it's never happened
right so you know so you're over and
under is what you're looking at you know
what's your best case scenario worst
case scenario and can you emotionally
handle the swing between those two
numbers
so john from a
psychology situation phd in psychology
you're in counseling
i was reading a study i don't know if
you've ever seen this data or not that
when someone loses money on an
investment
you have seen it like well you're
smiling when they when you lose money on
an investment if for every
dollar that you lose on an investment
to feel the same way
uh
emotionally you have to gain three
dollars
losses impact our emotions at a three to
one ratio
heavier
than gains
lift us emotionally yes i don't remember
the exact teeter-totter there but i know
daniel kahneman's just he's he changed
the world with his studies on that but
this idea and i'd never thought of this
dave i'm so
obsessed with losses that i don't think
about
non-future earnings right so we get so
obsessed with
yeah well and the reason is is that
you've experienced probably you may have
a scar yeah where you say okay i lost
that money and you know i i but you know
the stock market like people uh well
here's an example okay when in 2008 when
the market dropped from 13 000 to 6 400.
drop basically in half
uh the dow did
we had people and people will tell you
to this day that they lost all
of their retirement
in the 2008 downturn
well mathematically that's completely
impossible it's inaccurate right it's
completely impossible that you lost all
of your retirement if it was in mutual
funds
you lost half of it
if you happen to buy at the very top
and you happen to be the most unlucky
person in the world when you chose to
sell at the exact bottom you would have
lost half of your money
um
and by the way it's not at 6 500 today
it's close to you know north of what 30
000 today so 40 000. so
um you know that the dow jones
industrial average in other words so
that you know market is up 5x from the
bottom there
but in that effort to lose you know
to emotionally recover from that
downturn you completely avoided the
market since 2008 you've you've missed
that your million dollars would have
been five or six million right or we see
this especially missed out on when you
put five thousand dollars or twenty
thousand or a hundred thousand dollars
or a million into your company and your
company's not doing well
we're so loss averse that we keep
dumping money into that thing instead of
cutting our losses and moving yeah it's
very difficult especially when it's a
small business person who their dreams
or identity are tied up that's right
yeah you just do it with marriages too
we just keep going and we don't stop and
have conversations yeah we say uh
necessary endings yeah buddy henry cloud
right
uh bill in traverse city michigan hey
bill what's up
hey dave how are you
better than i deserve how can we help
um what dollar amount should we have set
aside for uh long-term care
and we're just kind of wondering if
we're going to make it with our current
finances
what's your net worth
uh 2.8 million not counting real estate
you made it you're good
you made it good so go nursing home
shopping in traverse city
and you know find the highest and the
lowest
and one you can reasonably do also talk
to uh some in-home care specialists that
will furnish round-the-clock care in
your home which you have enough money to
do that instead and it's sometimes not
even as much as a nursing home okay
and here's your averages the average
nursing home stay in america is 2.3
years
the average cost is 75 to 80 000 a year
times 2.3
okay so you have a 200 000
exposure
with a 2 million net worth you made it
now
let's say you had something happen that
was twice as bad as average can we agree
that statistically that's unlikely twice
as bad as average
that'd be 400 000
right
right you're still not broke the person
that's left is still a multi-millionaire
oh let's just say that statistically
it's highly unlikely that it was three
times
the average and you spent six hundred
thousand dollars on immersed nursing
home you're still actually fine
still a multi-millionaire with real
estate bill what makes you think you're
going to run out
there's something beneath this question
um just a lot of our neighbors
their parents are
having situations and i'm like
um my wife in our early 50s and we're
like man we don't want to strap our kids
with
this type of situation and they're
scrambling you know what i mean so
unless you do your nursing home in trump
tower
you're going to be okay
okay
i feel better you guys are working you
still got 20 more years of work left
yeah so and you know and by the way
let's just say you know the the the
percentage of people that go into a
nursing home prior to 60 is less than
one half of one percent okay so let's
say you got another 10 years anyway oh
let's say you got another 14 years this
is all going to double two more times if
you've got it invested decently
during this time you're gonna have a 10
million dollar net worth by the time you
address this issue
and then again go shopping and have some
actual facts and say okay here's the
nursing home we would choose and today
it is 110 000 today it is 85 000
and the average is 2.3 years
and um
if we're triple the average are we still
okay
easily easily easily and oh here's what
in-home care if i hired a nurse
full-time bought a hospital bed and
dropped 50 grand on medical equipment
for that room to take care of my wife
because i didn't want her to be in a
nursing home and i've got 10 million
dollars so we're going to do this at
home
with full-time care
a plus blue ribbon care what's that
going to run 150 grand maybe
you know
and this is world-class everything
so i'm making these numbers up but i'm
not far off so once you get actual
numbers instead of my opinion on them
and you put them down on paper and you
look at them compared to the money you
have you're gonna go we're self-insured
we're good and it's always important
when you're sitting around with a group
of people and everybody's talking about
the end of the time get a counterbalance
which is what he did he called somebody
and said give me another perspective on
this yeah and it's always good to get
another perspective on a problem always
and lastly
your neighbors
that are worrying about all this
likely don't have your net worth dude
that's right
very likely because you haven't told
them yours but i'm betting you that they
don't have your net worth
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's john delony co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we talk about your
relationships your boundaries your
mental health your job your career your
money and your life right here on the
ramsey show triple eight eight two five
five
two two five and is in columbia south
carolina starting off this hour hey ann
what's up
cj it's good to talk to you you too um
i haven't i don't know what to do
my husband just died within the last
week or so oh my
and
and
i went to call my sister only to find
out that her husband had died in
february
so
my sounding board
we're both in the same boat
but the reason i called is because i
don't know exactly
what i should be doing in in terms
of
the mortgage
i
received a
letter from the mortgage company where
they were doing the annual escrow
analysis
and they've upped the mortgage payment
almost a thousand dollars
and how old are you
76
how old was your husband
85
what happened
he fell at home
and
he went to the va hospital and they in
turn transferred transfer into a
civilian hospital and seven days later
he died they don't know exactly why he
died they were guessing
they initially admitted him to a
co-reward
and then a day and a half later they
changed him to a regular ward
but
hospital they called the psychiatrist
called it a hospital psychosis
he just really
um
he tore his clothing off he
tore his
medical devices off and uh
uh just with a
saying i'm sorry
not some nice thing
what was his name
monroe
so i do have children
he has three grown children
i have three grown children they're all
on their own
okay which one of your three children is
the responsible one
my daughter
it didn't take didn't take long to come
up with that name call her today okay
well
i thought about that when i first heard
about your daughter and tell her
and tell her you need some help
okay because you're sounding bored the
sounding board you used to use we're
gonna change out for your daughter okay
okay she's gonna be your sounding board
we're gonna help you too we're not gonna
leave you okay
but i need her in your life walking with
you
as you start making these different
decisions because one week after your
husband passes and you all were married
for many many years is not a good time
well actually it was a
it was a
third marriage for both of us and
we we had been married for 15 years many
years yeah
and so it's a tough day it's a tough
week it's a tough year for you
and i don't want you making big
financial decisions like the lone ranger
right now the lone ranger even needed
tonto
okay so let's get your we're gonna get
her in your corner i'm also gonna when
we get through i'm gonna put you on hold
and i'm gonna have one of our coaches
ramsay coaches that are certified by us
help you
walk you through the financial details
of this and we're not going to charge
you a dime it's going to be completely
free okay
wow thank you okay
so we've got to make sure that because i
don't want something like an escrow
account that could just be messed up to
throw you into a tizzy and cause you to
sell a house while you're in the midst
of this grief
because it's hard to think clear right
now if i'm you anyway
you're right
you just don't know which way to
turn
is there was there a life insurance
policy and is the house in your name are
you able to stay where you are is what
i'm getting at
um
it was a
rite of survivorship so it's out of the
estate
uh the estate doesn't affect it
and uh
are you gonna be able to buy groceries
on monday
uh
yeah i guess
i don't need a lot since i'm do you have
money do you have money
do you have money
i i i think i think i think i do
okay so here here's
the first things we need to do
is to make sure that you got these four
walls taken care of that you've got food
that you can keep the lights on and the
water running you gotta
some kid isn't gonna come knock on the
door one of his children and say that's
my house now and your name's not on the
deed so that i want your daughter and
the coaches will walk you through this
but your daughter's gonna help you with
the basics because that's to help you
sleep
okay
and when you don't know where i'm going
to get groceries if there is a life
insurance policy that i'm supposed to
get somewhere when you don't know those
things it is scary scary scary on top of
this tragic loss right
right well it was totally unexpected
that's right
we had talked about rehab and going to
that and the things he needed to do in
order to get there and yeah
it sounds like it's out of the blue and
that those that first six months that
first year that first two years can be
an absolute
black fog yeah and that's why you gotta
have someone you love walking next to
you yeah call your daughter as soon as
you hang up with us
and then uh we will have one of our
coaches call you uh within 24 hours and
we'll make sure you've got food money
set up and we'll make sure that you've
got a good budget and you got a good
handle on where you are somebody walking
with you and helping you do this stuff
and again we don't need any payment from
this this is uh
my bible says to take care of widows and
that's what i'm doing so um and it's our
honor to do that for you so you hang on
and jenna will pick up and we'll get you
connected up with a um
with a coach to help you walk through
this and um
because you're when you get some of the
basics done like john is saying and you
lay that
you know food is okay and you know the
lights and water is okay and you know i
got a place to live
suddenly it helps your mind start to
clear because right now it's all jumbled
up and it's uh
like you're juggling flaming swords in
your head or something and i'm gonna
lean in and say that her her husband did
this
i want every husband listening to this
call to hear that voice
if you don't have a will
if you have not sat down with your wife
and said here's where this stuff is
here's what the here's what happens next
here's where the paper is and where the
drawer is where the paper is
listen to her voice i don't know if i've
got food next week
do not be that husband yep
and why by the way wives those of you
that are handling the money your husband
doesn't know what's going on same goes
for you
you guys get on the same page and have a
plan
hang on jen i'll pick up and we'll take
care of you anne this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today guys we get it you're
struggling with money it's all consuming
you're wondering if your check is going
to clear if you can even afford to fill
up at the gas station
it's always on your mind but you
shouldn't have to live with this kind of
stress and you don't have to when you
follow a proven plan you'll discover
peace
with your money
a budget is a money stretcher it makes
your money go further and gives you a
sense of power in uncertain and crazy
times in financial peace university will
teach you how to do that we've taught
almost 10 million people how to budget
save spend wisely get out of debt and
become wealthy and outrageously generous
watching the course online right now and
joining a class even at your local
church
man it just changes everything
knowledge in the midst of uncertainty
brings peace
you are transformed by the renewing of
your mind decide today that you're done
letting money stress rule over your life
you can do this financial peace
university you can do a free trial
ramsey solutions dot com slash fpu check
out the free trial for financial peace
university at ramseysolutions.com
fpu our question today comes from
blinds.com they're the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings
incredible company free samples free
shipping and with new promos all the
time you'll save even more use the promo
code ramsey today's question comes from
shelly in tennessee and shelly writes
when we got married my husband wanted to
live on a budget we paid off our house
which is in his name and lived debt free
two years ago he suddenly stopped living
on any type of budget his spending is so
extreme now that money has had to be
transferred from our savings to pay
bills several times
i had to separate my finances from his
and started working full time after he
continued to abuse our shared money and
threatened me with divorce
now he's demanding that i combine
finances again to get access to my
paycheck
i'm trying to save for an attorney in
housing if we divorce i'm not in a
dangerous situation so i'm not in a
hurry to divorce until i'm prepared
financially i don't want to hide funds
from the government but i do want to
hide funds from my spouse is there any
way i can protect myself financially
while pacifying
my spouse
nope nope
[Music]
nope
this is um time for you to sit down with
a marriage counselor and with your
pastor
and develop um
something more than a radio answer for
something that's important in your life
and uh but it sounds like that it's
gonna
what you're gonna develop with them is
the ability to have a conversation with
your husband that says
either this
or that if then now
and uh it's called the ultimatum and
that's where you are
i think people often get abuse and
we think of physical safety
like i'm being hit
this woman is unsafe this is financial
that's right she's about psychologically
uncertain homeless she's a psychological
abuse this is highly trump this is a
terrible environment to be in a terrible
environment to be in and if they're
because he's obviously
involved in something right that's right
he's either an addict of some that's my
guess here he's an addict or he's with
somebody else or something who knows or
both or both that's right um and so my
the one thing i want to call out here is
the number of couples who are divorced
and live together and torture each other
they stay married but in spirit and in
finances and in life they are living two
separate lives they're already divorced
they just never admitted it yes
they
like you're prepping for a divorce
you're ready for divorce i'm not in a
hurry well honey you've already
crossed the line there then and now what
you're choosing to do is torture
yourself torture this guy who's clearly
gone off and it's just you've made a
mess this isn't something to just kind
of him all around you're not safe
he owns the house right all it's just a
mess get with somebody a professional
today
he's a mess man yeah and and and make a
a narrative up that says um
you don't stop this
we're done yeah
if i'm not safe to be in my own home
yeah if you you don't stop yeah the
extreme spending and you don't stop the
manipulation
and you don't stop
the out of control aspects of your life
were done so
i you know 30 years i i've been doing
this um
i'm going to give you a wild but maybe
not so wild
guess cocaine
this fits cocaine yeah it's hyper it's
hyped up
uh out of control
energetic
frenetic
he is
because everything he's doing he's doing
wide open and somewhat out of the blue
was this way now is that randomly yeah
it just fits the fits the pattern for me
i'm not a professional i'm just an old
guy that's seen a lot yeah and um
which is kind of the same thing by the
way but same exact thing that's that's
the definition of wisdom right
but yeah but i mean it could it may not
be it may be it may be a girlfriend it
may be a porn addiction this may there
may be 73 prostitutes in the background
on this but there's something extreme
yeah there's no little tiny
i'm having an emotional affair at the
office that's not here or a major
psychiatric is whatever some kind of
blow up schism
before
nuts here
and so i don't
based on that i i i don't think when you
present the either or
that you're going to get an either
you're just going to get an or
you're probably you're going to be gone
and be ready for that yeah you bet
expect to be leaving
instantaneously and uh go ahead and do
that and you don't need a house you just
need an apartment uh you know you got a
paycheck just take your paycheck you've
been living on that anyway and if you've
paid equity into this home as part of
the divorce settlement he'll have to
write you a check yeah and if you see my
kids he's gonna have to write child
support and if you've been married a
long time in most states he's going to
write alimony and that's all part of the
divorce and you can get the attorney
later it's you don't have to stay there
and you shouldn't another minute you
need to go sit with someone
and have someone else look at this long
form not a two minute radio answer this
is your life it is your marriage but
that's our perception reading in from
the outside that you got a mess on your
hands that does not it does appear to
have gone beyond
the point of no return but we'll see
maybe we're wrong maybe i'm wrong i hope
i'm wrong hope i'm wrong
so a new story as gas prices continue to
increase across the nation by now pay
later companies like clarna and zip have
partnered with gas stations to provide
consumers with options to stretch out
their payments
so you can fill up the old truck now and
not have to worry about the payments for
a while
which you could have done with your
stupid gas credit card anyway how stupid
is this i mean it was already available
to you
critics of buy now pay later that would
be me
have pointed out evidence that consumers
are having trouble keeping up with all
of their pay letter payments yes they
are clarner clarna
and zip are man these guys are just
ripping the hearts out of a certain
segment of our population and feeding
them back to them it's ridiculous
um i mean this makes the old credit card
debt thing when i first got started
looked like easy
this right here is just straight up evil
this is this is robbing
people who are struggling yeah and
really what you're doing let me tell you
when you finance gas
or groceries
in any method credit card clerna
anything
because you've been watching the news so
much because if you watch the 24 news
right now
all you're hearing are people with their
vocal cords really tight
really dramatic
really amped up
over caffeinated looking at the camera
screaming at you that inflation is going
to kill you
you're going to die of inflation
you're never going to be able to eat
you're never going to be able to fill up
your car
and you certainly will never buy a house
again and it's all this evil monster
inflation's fault if you and you're
going to die you're going to die you're
going to die it is the latest form of
fear porn on the news channel if you did
the matrix and barely dodged covid here
comes inflation it's coming right at you
well if you keep watching it'll be a
tornado next i mean it's going to be
unbelievable the fear porn these guys
they cannot drive ratings except with
adrenaline apparently hey i do i did
hear this i found a place where you can
get two dollar gas
arby's
that was two chelsea i'm sorry you're 13
years old that's true to god you're
i thought that was a great joke
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free
shipping with blinds.com there's no need
to renovate your entire home just change
out what's on your windows with upscale
choices like faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage
brian and elena are with us hey guys how
are you
great welcome where do you all live
brandon mississippi all right welcome to
nashville how much debt have you paid
off
305 thousand whoa whoa how long did this
take five years wow and your range of
income during that time um
160. you can get it you can get it it's
about 160 to about 300 000. okay 160 to
300. oh wow what do y'all do for a
living
i work for a power company i'm a
simulation healthcare educator wow good
very cool okay so 305 000 over five
years i'm gonna guess and say that might
have been your house yeah that's right
yeah totally different yeah look at it
where people that's right i love it so
cool you guys are awesome what's this
house worth
um with the market changes i would say
about 450 000. i like it we count the
market changes they're good yeah nice
job
well done well done well done how have
you guys been doing on your investing
for your 401ks and everything doing
great i mean
we've seen
huge improvements yeah excellent so how
much have you got your nest egg built
too we're right now our net worth we're
we're now officially millionaires baby
step millionaires
yeah i like it
well done we actually paid off the house
and became millionaires within the same
year i like it that's so fun good for
you
how old are you guys 39 both of us both
of you millionaires before you're 40.
yes and paid for everything yes no more
driving penny stuff happens to other
people but you did it
i'm so proud of y'all wow so cool okay
so what happened
um we decided to get focused um we
downsized our vehicles and we started
driving uh what we were called around
town as penny pincher and stinky minnow
stinky what stinky minnow what was it
it was a 2012 uh chevy colorado oh you
nicknamed the cars that yeah oh i
thought you were calling him that
well she probably called me worse but
now my dad actually took the truck it
was a little single cab truck without
power windows or locks and uh they
actually spilled a bucket of minnows in
there so
it had a smell in it for a while
we still drove it though that's the
stinky minnow i got it okay yeah you got
to give these cars a nickname so now
it's time to get some better cars y'all
yes we did just do that we drove it here
oh what did you get uh a chevy caller uh
chevy silverado nice that's a good truck
paid off good no mental smell at all
lot less fighting in the back seat
because it has a back seat yeah oh
there's that yeah
if you don't behave we'll put you all
the way right
way to go you guys okay so you decide to
get serious
focus in and then what happened
um we wanted to be good less than teach
them good lessons so we
we tried to help her learn how to keep
a job even when she was like 12.
so she started painting mailboxes in the
neighborhood and she started um pitch
fitting
on rover and so she actually started her
roth ira so we were trying to set a good
example for her
but this whole process started because
we wanted to change our family tree so
we we grew up we we weren't um
poor but we didn't have everything we
wanted so we wanted to make sure that we
could
teach them the right way to live and
that we could sustain that and um change
generations to come so that was really
important for us yeah very good so what
can you get how much can you get paint
in the mailbox that's pretty cool yeah
she can't she didn't got a mic you
answered yeah she was getting about 50
50 to 70 dollars a mission
now like i said we we sanded it down
yeah you got a couple of did good work
on it oh yeah any run she learned she
had to sand that down so she didn't want
to spray too much in one area so
it was it was a good life lesson for her
so she uh she did it all over herself i
mean big kudos to her she was phenomenal
well i mean you do ten of those a month
that turned into some money that's right
yeah she made she made over three
thousand that summer
oh yeah that's good income she had roth
ira now so yeah there you go say i
couldn't even spell roth was it that's
good yeah you guys that's amazing well
done very well done okay now that you
did it you paid off house and everything
in five years
and you hit the baby steps millionaires
mark what do you tell people the secret
to getting out of debt and building
wealth is
i mean really to me it's just focus you
know having a common goal making sure
that you know you know what you're
striving toward you know setting a
better example for your kids and letting
them know that you know there there is a
being weird is not a bad thing i guess
so let me ask you this um and to two
kids y'all need to do earmuffs on this
one what was the
mom and dad
y'all make a great salary
and there's gotta be mornings you woke
up and opened that truck and it smelled
so bad and you thought what
like i'm honey well i'm done with this
i'm at least getting a grown-up car
because i have a grown-up right and you
start rationalizing what's the biggest
fight you all had
really to me i think really wasn't
vehicles um
i think it was more vacation she's used
to growing up she grew up having a lot
of vacations and going from a lot of
vacations to taking local trips and
staying with family
that was a big change for us so that was
that was probably the biggest fights
that we've had some good knock down drag
out ones a matter of fact
so we plan on taking a lot of vacations
well you can go anywhere you want to go
now yes you're millionaires and you
don't have any debt how would you tell
somebody to get through that somebody
who's used to traveling like this is
just the way we do summer and all of a
sudden that's not how we're gonna do it
for the next five years
how would you coach somebody through
that it's just temporary and so just
plan where you want to go and just know
it's just going to take a little bit
longer to get there
but you can do it together
yeah
wow now you can go yeah you can go
anywhere anywhere you want to go
literally i mean that's pretty
impressive so very cool you guys good
job outside of you guys who was your
biggest cheerleaders cheering you on we
had um some neighbors in our um uh
neighborhood that had paid their house
off and then i had some girls at work
and they had paid their house off so
just hearing that other people had done
it and so it wasn't an impossible dream
that we could actually do it too well
you end up around people that are you
know that are positive influence instead
of a bunch of negatives that's right
that's cool that makes a big difference
makes a big difference and it's nice to
be able to make positive influences on
other people you know last year i bought
all my employees the dave ramsey book
and one of my employees she actually
called me right before christmas and she
said i'm selling my card and it's your
fault
well i'm gonna blame dave
[Laughter]
well if you're driving the minnow the
stinky minnow then you can you can
probably do that that'll work yeah i
should have told her have i got a truck
for you
[Laughter]
sorry but i don't feel sorry yeah it's
going to be worth it no discipline seems
pleasant at the time but it yields a
harvest of righteousness you guys are
amazing i'm so proud of you well done
and i love 75 mailboxes this is not one
i've heard i will repeat this and tell
people tell teenagers in other cities i
won't create competition for you but
i'll tell teenagers in other cities that
they should do this well i've heard that
if
your kids work that they just vanish
they die and so
i'm seeing somebody who worked hard and
did really well and now is planning for
a future beyond most adults these days
so good for you have you had the fir
have you all had the first
paycheck deposit that's all yours oh
yeah feels good huh it does it feels
real good it's like where did it all
come from what oh where was it all cars
where was it all going
so well love it guys we got a copy of
baby steps millionaires for you you are
one but you should have been in there
but you now you know what it looks like
and uh you'll be able to share that with
someone else maybe and also a copy of
total money makeover for you to share to
someone else pay it forward so good
stuff well done you guys all right it's
305 000 paid off in five years making
160 to 300 brian elena adeline and
fisher from jackson mississippi count it
down let's hear a debt free scream one
two three
[Music]
[Applause]
house and everything we're looking at
weird people here
oh man that's about as fun as it gets
i'll just tell you
making their kids work pretty pretty
stinking incredible i'm working hard
it's amazing yeah i love it very well
done
very well done
kids disappear if they work huh who knew
[Laughter]
[Music]
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
our scripture today isaiah 40 31 but
those who hope in the lord will renew
their strength they will soar on wings
like eagles they will run and not grow
weary they will walk and not be faint
vince lombardi said confidence is
contagious so is lack of confidence
you know that's true and
the thing that comes up is um
thinking about the studies that show
that uh
if your three closest friends are obese
the height the probability that you will
be is unbelievably high if your three
closest friends of your ten closest
friends your income will be the average
of your 10 closest friends um
and
these are people that have influence and
the last
debt free screamer said you know i had
this person paid off this neighbor paid
off their house this coworker paid off
their house and there were people around
them
even at one degree of separation that
we're paying off their houses and that
increases the probability that you're
gonna pay off your house very high and
earlier we had a caller from who's a
multi-millionaire who hung out with a
bunch of people that said our parents
aren't gonna make it and then the times
is here and they call us saying hey are
we going to be okay
and they're in their 50s and they got a
net worth of two points something
million dollars not including the real
estate and it yeah you're gonna be okay
right so it's who you hang out with
you're yeah you nailed it yeah there's a
the
and the data on
the that if you know someone that knows
someone
that you don't have one degree of
separation
how that impacts things like wealth uh
income
uh marital stability uh obesity uh it's
crazy the impact that community
has on you that you're you know
wondering out two rings out of your
community that you and the thing is you
can choose that yeah
uh you can choose you know if you're
gonna if you're gonna get sober
continuing to run around with your old
drinking buddies probably ain't gonna
work out hello and there's so much power
in this idea of
a picture somebody that looks i can see
myself in this that's why debt free
screams are so important because they
cover such a broad range of different
people it's easier to see one group as a
couple and be like ah that's not us
we've found one that looks like i can go
oh i could see myself doing that i know
somebody who's done this my friend has
done this that means i can do it that's
so powerful yep it does change
everything someone from our community
someone from our city some from one from
our region someone that has an accent
that sounds like ours so here's what's
important when i find myself in these
negative cycles and i'm just being
honest like the news been hard and for
some reason this particular cycle is got
me down
i the the further down the oh no rabbit
hole i go i've now been with myself long
enough to stop and say where where am i
getting input from who am i getting
input from and invariably it's
i'm not talking to real people enough
and i'm on my phone too much almost
almost all the time
yeah are you following someone on
facebook
that is in your past
and should have stayed in your past
right yes
but you're real concerned about what
they're doing yeah and they're they're
really not in your future they're in
your past nothing to do with who you are
now and all that's doing is feeding your
your stinking mind you're stinking
thinking that's what all uh ziggler used
to say zig ziglar the stinking thinking
and um you know it it that stuff is real
it's very very real it's real it ha
there's data to back it up there's
research to back it up and if you just
think about it it rings true with your
heart when you hear it that you become
who you hang around with right so do not
evil company corrupts good habits
in your life yeah it's very real it
matters a lot that you do that and so
it's um you know who you hanging around
with
are your buddies you know are they
running around on their wife right or
are there you know well let me just tell
you your likelihood of infidelity just
went through the roof right i mean
because you're just hanging out with
people that normalize this misbehavior
you know it's just not okay
um are you hanging out with people who
say this is not okay right you know it
changes everything it changes
everything so it's good stuff confidence
is contagious so is lack of confidence
courage is contagious so is lack of
courage
and when you stand up and say as for me
and my house
we're not doing this yep
we're not going to be those people you
give people around you permission and
sometimes it takes you being that person
if one person will stand up and say i'm
staying here
i'm standing here to fight i'm staying
here we don't do this in our house you
give somebody else permission to say
well yeah then we don't either right and
it just
takes one one person yeah because they
were thinking it anyway yeah you just
you just gave voice to what they were
already thinking yeah you know we're as
for me and my house we don't borrow
money yeah and you know we're it's for
me and my house we give a lot we're not
in my house we will be outrageously
generous we're gonna be known for our
tipping we're gonna be known for
these things and uh it just it changes
everything when you do that and we're
gonna be known for excellence we're
gonna be knowing for
showing up on time we're gonna be known
for
whatever i mean you you list it out and
you just make that decision and i love
when i'm hearing your podcast and you're
talking about you know starting to say
the values of the family that's what
deliveries are that's right this is who
it alone is it's who a ramsay is as for
as for me and my house this is who we
are
and uh
and you're giving identity then to the
whole family yeah that this is who we
are and families do that negatively too
oh yeah we oh we're we're just not an
exercising family or we're we're a pizza
family or uh
we're uh what like we just aren't good
with money fam the worst one i ever
heard on that was henry cloud was on the
show one day and uh ladies said well you
know we have a obesity in our family no
one it runs in our family and he said no
no one runs in your face oh gosh
of course henry said that
come on cloud
no no one runs in your family
[Laughter]
but you know that's the thing right
there you just you know our family just
has you know we're all we're all just
have tempers well and then here's what
you know it gets hard nope we're just
we're we're not those kind of people
we're we're poor that's who we are yeah
we don't have we don't drive cars like
that we don't buy houses and then and
then if someone if one of your cousins
decides he's going to make a little
money you go oh you're getting above
your races
you're getting above your ratings
yeah i always wondered what a rate why
why raisin came into this a shriveled up
grape how did this come into this or
the
yeah we raised you to be less than
you better get back down on the ground
where we better you better be poor like
everybody else i mean come on you uppity
yeah oh yeah and you can do that with a
southern accent or you can do that with
an author so we've met with my fair
share of parents who are
we're lawyers in this family we're
doctors that kid's not going to go be a
missionary that kid's not gonna go
be a teacher this is who we are it's
like well that's who your daughter is so
she you can choose be in a relationship
with her or not but she's gonna go teach
or she's going to the mission field or
whatever right so it all comes back to
uh who are we here's the thing yeah the
point of all this is if you will
intentionally decide
okay this is who we are yeah
and just start
and then just start saying it and start
doing it you know over time
it is absolutely proven that you will
become that yep you know we're just
people that do this okay then we do this
and then didn't do this when you don't
your kid
this may be the pot talking to the
kettle hey we we the delonies we tip
well that's what we're kind of known for
we tip well we're gonna always honor
these folks
and then the one time i just scribble in
five bucks hit my
six-year-old goes daddy we we tip well
and you're like okay i see what i mean
so put a one in front of you
right so they'll keep everybody keeps
everybody accountable that's what
community does that's right that is it
and and so
that's why it's important for people
that are wanting to engage in spiritual
growth to actually attend
if you run to people yeah actually
attend a church yes and and uh it's the
problem with online only yeah
uh you actually need to be in community
you need to be in physical proximity
that's right with these humans that you
want to be like yes
and uh it will cause you to be like them
and it doesn't work online you can't
zoom it in no you can't zoom it out you
can't zoom it in yeah it's communication
not connection man it's uh it's there's
and there's more about communication
that happens in a physical proximity
than in any other way right and so this
is just real y'all yeah and um
it's it's a big deal it's a big deal so
that all comes from that vince lombardi
quote there kind of got us on this ramp
but it's a good rant so
if you want to be debt-free and generous
start running around with people who
want to be debt-free and generous if you
want to be people who read books instead
of watch tv start running around with
people who read books instead of watch
tv and that hug their spouse and hug
their kids
and that are right upstanding good
generous courageous people
just pick who you want to be and make
sure those are the people in your life
doesn't mean you're not nice to the
other ones
just means you're not they're not your
posse that's all it means
that puts us our the ramsay show in the
books we'll be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
prince of peace christ jesus
[Music]
hey it's john deloney co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
you